hey everybody it's time for street it's
thursday it's time for our astro coffee
hangout with dr brian keating my name is
tony darnell
and we are going to be talking about the
theory of
well i guess more than one now theories
of everything
and uh we couldn't do this last time
because we had some
stupid connection issues now uh we've we
just resorted back to zoom our old
standby
and things are fine so let me go ahead
and pull brian up here
uh you there brian i am here
so tell us about why your video looks
the way it does and where are you
i'm in a mountain time zone near jackson
hall wyoming
for a very special event which will be
taking place with uh yours truly and
and um i don't know how do you say the
other guys truly
uh tony and i are going to be part of a
very special
virtual stargazing event that's taking
place
uh that's taking place tonight that's
right uh eight o'clock
pacific nine o'clock mountain 11 o'clock
tony's time east coast time that's right
and it's with
the most amazing telescopes that any
amateur astronomer i've ever met has
this guy's a
phenomenal person he's done tremendous
amounts of
astronomy with his home
observatory which has almost the same
collecting areas the hubble telescope
and it is uh very fitting that we're
celebrating
the hubble because this is its 30th
birthday it's tony noms
so tonight every single star party that
we're waiting i thought that was april
20th
april wow okay it's april but it's like
it's a year come on oh okay that's a yes
it is 30 years uh yeah in april
of 20 of 1990 actually it launched
that's right so yeah
yeah can you believe it so what we yeah
what we tried to do is
celebrate give hubble a birthday party
but also
all these star parties that we used to
go to as kids and take our kids to
they're all canceled because of that c
word that no one can say
yeah and have their youtube videos
monetized still
so what we're trying to do is rekindle
that with the virtual star party
where we're going to cover none other
than the birthday telescope's greatest
hits
so i put some links in the live chat
uh tony will uh puts them in the his
maybe the permanent chat although it's
only happening tonight so
if you miss it you won't be able to
catch it live and probably record it
right but uh it'll be on my youtube
channel tony's youtube channel as well
yeah we'll be streaming starting at 11
o'clock this evening on my time
uh do the math on wherever time zone
you're in but that's eastern time and
uh i don't know we'll stream for an hour
too i'm not quite sure how long we'll be
on but um
it's gonna after about two hours i'm
gonna be fading i can tell you that so
it'll be oh yeah it'll be one o'clock my
time so we'll see how it goes so yeah
stick around uh
tonight and join us for this virtual
star party i know you guys out in europe
i'll be way late in the morning for you
guys but early in the morning for you
guys but uh
try if you can make it anyway okay so
the link to that by the way
is all on this on my channel and if you
set the little bell for the uh
notification you'll get notified if
you're on brian's channel
the link to his channel is also in my
description box just uh click on
and notifying uh the event on his
channel did you set the event up yet
brian
on your channel for tonight i don't i
don't know how to do that let's check it
out afterwards
okay you hit the notification you'll get
it yeah um theory of everything so
you just did a thing why don't you uh
this was a few weeks ago you did an
online thing with uh
with several um physicists and you
talked about
a theory of everything now when we
didn't get um
connected i just gave everybody uh my
opinions on this
during during that stream so check that
out to get what my thoughts are on it
but uh what did so tell us about what
you did and what was going on
so um not only was april the birthday of
the hubble telescope back in 1990
but in 1920 in april there was something
called the great debate and it was held
in the smithsonian institution in
washington dc
and it was a debate concerning whether
or not on the milky way galaxy is the
entire universe
or whether there are other island
universes and tiny
bit large galaxies that are different
from the quote-unquote tiny nebulae
that have the same kinds of appearance
that you see through your telescope
so it's a centennial of those great
debates and i made
friends with matt o'dowd who runs a very
popular channel called pbs spacetime
studios
on uh youtube and you can check that out
and that
that team the pbs spacetime studios team
and i created a webinar series of two
webinars
to which i added my own i'll describe uh
a little bit in a moment about what i
did separate from pbs
kind of i went rogue tony um no but it
was all
and yeah it was all in an attempt to
really capture the spirit of the times
the zeitgeist
sabina hassenfelder might say and it
concerned
whether or not there is a theory of
everything uh why there are so many
theories of everything if
as the highlander says there can be only
one why are there so many
and furthermore uh do we even need a
theory of everything which was asked by
a very eminent scientist
on this very channel not too long ago
and his name is tony darnell so tony you
gave me a homework assignment
to consult with the greatest scientist
in the world uh about whether we even
need
a theory of everything who's you know do
we need an 11th toe
and um and so i did that i took the
mission up
and i ended up speaking with elise
mullen
uh sabine hassenfelder eric weinstein
stefan alexander james beecham who's an
experimentalist who people don't know as
well
max tag mark and a tiny bit of lisa
randall
before a hurricane swept through
cambridge massachusetts and
took out her internet connection but
she's fine she assures me she's fine
so the greatest minds in the world that
are working on this one problem
through different approaches
experimental theoretical calculational
and it was a blast it was a total blast
i had a
i had a great deal of gratitude to those
guests and to matt o'dowd and his team
at space time studios they really run
a very very impressive organization
there two million
seventy or two million one hundred
thousand followers
wow yeah that's true they they do some
good content as well so uh the
did you uh uh and i put a link by the
way to
what brian's talking about in the
description box of this stream
so you can go watch the whole thing in
its entirety but um
so what's the consensus what are the
answers to some of those questions do we
even need a theory of anything
everything theory of anything well we
might need it
it turns out that when you have uh you
know six
eminent physicists you end up getting
you know ten ten
ten different answers uh which is kind
of surprising so
10 different theories yeah to that
question do we need a theory of
everything
um the approaches are what really
fascinated me and the question of
the impact of mathematics and
mathematical simplicity
mathematical beauty elegance etc that
seem to be overarching
the new theories of everything namely
that of wolfram
who wasn't a participant in the two pbs
episodes but he instead joined with me
and eric weinstein last thursday
uh for a very rip-roaring good time uh
where we put those two head-to-head as a
great mathematical physicist
and they they debated more not the
virtues of their own individual theories
although it was great to hear at least
to hear eric
explain steven's theory of everything
which is that the universe is somehow
computational
and that the universe organizes itself
along purely computational principles
following
relatively simple algorithms that can
then generate the laws of physics that
we observe
eric has a much more baroque byzantine
complex
uh complex theory of everything uh
called geometric unity
and it was funny because um i invited
sabina haasenfelder i don't know if we
talked about my podcast with her
on this channel we did we mentioned it
but yeah
in fact kent slayer on twitch is saying
sabine savages eric a couple of times
on the stream oh yeah so just yesterday
she came out with a video
music video uh really kind of chatting
him
in a humorous way about his theory and
also mentioning wolfram as well
and garrett lisey who's a friend of mine
from also
uh music he's a graduate of uc san diego
and he's remains a good friend he's got
his own theory this e8
theory and sabine is known for being
very polite and reserved no she's not
she's very cumbersomely
very much a pessimist so she savages
these fears yeah people are saying in my
chat that
sparks were flying in that conversation
there are also sparks falling in the
conversation with wolfram and weinstein
which is very
i don't know if you've ever had guests
on where the guests are like you know
kind of
battling each other uh people should
look at the video some say
eric won some say stephen one but the
one thing i really appreciate is eric
gave a
very good translation of steven's
theories
especially how we can convert them
into kind of simplified almost finding
like diagrams
to understand these terms that stephen
wolfram
proposes underline the meaning of
reality uh what was interesting is that
stephen didn't want to talk about
his theory and he didn't want to talk
about eric's theory even more
so in the chat i was kind of negotiating
between the two of them
and in the middle of all this uh was it
getting belligerent
i mean were they like really not wanting
to discuss the theories
no i think eric wanted to go for
everyone it was it was you know mostly
good nature and some people say in the
comments it wasn't
uh but uh stephen was you know kind of
particular he didn't want to talk about
the weeds
he said let's stop talking about this
let's talk about other things um but i
wanted to keep going in the weeds
because i know my listeners and
your listeners can handle it and i was
their voice
and so i was trying to do it and then
i'm getting all these text messages from
stephen let's move on let's do a
different topic
and uh and i love steve and then his
work so it was it was a little bit it
was kind of like you know
your parents get into a fight and you're
trying to make peace between them i
don't know if that ever happened to you
but
it happened to me i was so unsuccessful
my parents both were divorced twice
uh but anyway uh wow this theory that
stephen proposes
is uh is equally complex in fact it
might be even more
um complex i i call eric's complicated
in that you could reconstruct it if you
knew enough math
the problem is nobody seems to know the
math and then i had the pleasure of
having so then eric
came down to san diego you recall that
he's always accusing the physics
community
of not um of not engaging with him and
so my whole thing is i'm gonna put you
know my money where your mouth is eric
and we're going to get together and
we're going to hash this out
so he came down masks and gloves and we
went to work and we just sat at a white
board in my house
and hammered on these theories of
everything in his particular approach to
geometric unity
we made so much progress um and we're
kind of tentatively
agreeing on how we can pursue a joint
project together where we would
supervise a student to finally get some
of eric's work into publication
and i know that's what my audience wants
i know that's what you guys out there
want we want to actually write something
down
unlike steven who writes down books that
are this thick
and that nobody seems to read
but but he's obviously very very
successful
so uh that was kind of last week um and
i wanted to give steven a chance because
you know people like sabine are
savaging him and so i wanted to give him
a chance and we didn't have time and
space to include him on the spacetime
studios
podcast so instead we had a one-off and
that's on my youtube channel and on my
podcast channel into the impossible as
well
okay all right well um
i want to get into something that uh uh
alan lowey on uh
or loewy i think i'm not sure how to
pronounce it i was commenting eric
he says eric's theory is too complex to
be correct
and i want to drill so my question has
to do with
why does the theory of everything have
to be simple
and what would i mean what would a
characteristic of a theory just
general what would a characteristic of a
theory of everything need to have
uh i keep hearing that it's that it's uh
that it's gotta it's got to reconcile
relativity with quantum mechanics the
very big with the very small we've got
really good
notions of what happens uh
in the very large scales and we got
pretty good notion of what happens
in the very small scales but we can't
get them to connect
is that what it needs to be what what
has it got to be
well so that's a very good question one
thing i think
i disagree with the first part of the
question that it's too complicated
i think well i was just asking does it
need to be simple
uh a theory of error well okay but yeah
zerex is too complex according to alan
yeah so i'm addressing alan first so
alan hi
um uh yeah i agree it's complicated but
this is something i didn't really
realize until i was a physics
you know a graduate student that in the
1900s or sorry even the early 1900s
people didn't understand how to use
matrices like
matrix multiplication linear algebra and
things like that
and certainly tensors and vector
products etc those are very abstract
concepts
einstein had to basically consult with
some of the most eminent mathematicians
marcel grossman
and others of course riemann gauss and
and
not he didn't consult with him they were
dead but he used their work
to establish a bridge a codex
a rosetta stone that would translate
between the purely mathematical
descriptions of differential geometry
to physics so if you were alive back
then allen and there was a deep
astronomy
you know coffee table because there
wouldn't be a podcast
you might say oh this is too complicated
and yet with that einstein was able to
unify
or at least provide a mathematical
underpinning that unified mathematics
pure mathematics differential geometry
to understand how space-time curvature
affects the dynamics of motion so
so i would say complexity as you
describe it may well be true
and it may apply to me i don't i'm an
experimental i'm just a simple humble
experimental cosmologist all right so
i'm not i'm not a mathematician
but on the other hand i think it's
extremely important to go as deep as we
can and try and understand the limits of
what we can know
in mathematics understanding that the
ultimate test is experimental
and that's where all six of these people
kind of come up short in my opinion
they'll all say oh well the ultimate
test is experimental
but then they'll say well we need a
collider in the case of james beacham
you know the size of the solar system or
something or to actually test something
or they'll say we need this 20 billion
dollar future collider
and sabine will say well that's 20
billion dollars down the train because
there's no natural target
you're just going to say here we pour
money in here
and out comes serendipity on the other
side and i
agree with her in that context um it's
not enough to just say we're going to
find new things
so um so i'm getting questions in my
chat room from constantinos
you know how much do i believe eric's
theory so
you know again belief is always the
wrong word so the question is evidence
so his theory makes very specific
predictions
about the nature of things as important
to me as dark matter
as anti-matter and those things have to
be reconciled
with the theories of uh are the
observations
that we have of dark energy dark matter
new particles etc so i propose ways that
we can test it
but first i really need to understand it
and a lot of it i
understand you know i understand kind of
this
this um you know almost tapestry threads
of it but i don't understand the whole
of it
so that's why i'm going to recruit a
bright graduate student in the coming
year
to help me translate this into
experimental and moreover
cosmological predictions constantina so
that's when
i'll be able to say i can have belief or
evidence for it
or it might be impossible to ever get
evidence for it
and in that case that's the main
question because then that diverges from
the traditional scientific method i
think that's what darks you tony so much
yes i don't like things that can't be
ultimately dealt with
observationally or in any other way um
but
so do do these things have to connect
i mean do we need a theory of everything
yes or no
in order to do science do you think
there is one and do we need one
um i you know i think at this point
there what we're guided by is the fact
that
there are unifications of
electromagnetism
of electricity and magnetism and the
weak theory there's plant you know there
are
gut theories there's the sg2 cross um
sc3 cross su-2 cross u1 and those are
all group theory structures
those are incredibly successful the
thing that's missing from that so if you
if you said you know you've got um uh
you know
uh i'm trying to make a good analogy
here if you have you know something that
that
gets you you're reading a book and the
first three chapters
you know it's progressing it makes total
sense um everything
needs to be you know coming together
story's really good it loses your it
doesn't lose your interest you can't
stop turning the pages and then the
fourth chapter is just like totally out
there it's about
you know the iran contra affair and and
this is like a murder mystery
that takes place in cancun and what the
heck is going on here
it doesn't play nice um so the
expectation after the first three
chapters is that the fourth chapter be
like the first three
but maybe maybe it's totally different
right tony i mean there's no
law of nature that says we have to have
a law of nature
that can be written on our t-shirts
that's right but what i think is
important is that
there i see from all these mathematical
physicists
i see very little chance that um
that there are other theories that are
plausible
testable falsifiable other than these
theories in other words just kind of
like you know
there's a difference between something
that's complicated tony like building a
747
and something that's complex like trying
to build a sand castle like
when you build a sand castle every time
you build it it's different
and it depends very sensitively on that
very first sand grain you drop down
that forms the base that's called
sensitivity to initial conditions
is a hallmark of complex systems now
getting
a building a 747 isn't easy but if you
follow the blueprints you'll build the
exact same one every single time it
doesn't matter if that day was a tuesday
that you started
and it was raining or it was a wednesday
and it was sunny
so that's the difference complicated and
complex i think there's an abstract
notion in my mind that the theory of
everything will either be
complex or complicated eric's theory is
very complicated
it uses you know these 14-dimensional
structures
it uses mathematical projections
it uses all sorts of notions of what
dark matter
and dark energy would be that's very
complicated because you have to learn
the structure of math you need a math
phd essentially
although i don't have one and i i
believe i can't see the
the end i can't even see the the
beginning of the end as winston
churchill said but i can see the end of
the beginning
and in that sense it gives me hope that
he's spanning the vector space
of possible theories of everything that
are complicated
does that make sense but wolfram spans
the perpendicular direction
in hilbert space or mathematical theory
space and those are theories that are
complex
so i think some of those people you know
one camp will be right i
noted as i'm debating as i was listening
to the debate kind of separating the
fighters
from when they went toe to toe uh pun
intended
i said one of these guys they can't they
can't subsume each other's theories
only one can be right and they didn't
want to you know kind of
fight each other but i think they
believe that too that they're right the
other guy's wrong
and that's fine you need a little bit of
confidence almost arrogance to make
progress in this field
well and that's also how you know
science is done i mean
somebody's right and the rest are wrong
and they will
it'll come out in the process so that's
what's supposed to happen
anyway um uncle bill's commenting we
have been spoiled by the simple
elegance of kepler newton and einstein
that does not mean the next step will be
so elegant personally i think it will be
but that's wishful thinking that's true
we have these biases
um you know sort of
all the time and
[Music]
it's like ken slater saying i think it
does have to reconcile quant gravity and
quantum and doesn't need to be simple
it needs to be testable and verifiable
that's a good comment
and we be good says yes it will be
simple and elegant
so there's this preference for simple
and elegant things
that make us happy and feel good and
that we can put on a t-shirt
um i i am far from convinced that any of
this is necessary but
again we don't we're not complete we
need we need a more
complete view of what's going on in the
universe we clearly don't have that yet
so this will get us closer and if it
really does connect one thing to another
and doesn't make us have to depend on
strings
and multi-worlds then yay
do any of these go there i mean do any
of these theories that you were talking
about
without they all they all go there so we
end up somewhere that's basically
fantasyland
well you know look when you look at
wolfram's theory so he's got this theory
that describes
uh complex systems in terms of simple
looking
mathematical laws they're not simple in
the sense they're they're
fundamental in the sense that you know
an electron is a fundamental building
block of
of nature it doesn't mean it's simple to
understand an electron you need the
dirac equation
you need these things called spinners
you need um
a notion of hilbert space all these
different things are necessary to
describe something that's
elementary like if you went to
elementary school and they start
teaching you about hilbert space you
know i got a recommendation for another
school
so it doesn't mean easy i mean in this
case wolf from what he has done
it's it's tantalizing because he
describes
a theory that is successful at
describing
fractals crystal growth biological
systems
entropy and and so i asked him
well what what makes you think that it
has something to say about the
underpinnings of the laws of physics
in other words will you get out of it
the fundamental
constants of nature the mass of the
electron
the speed of light and to some of those
he said yes and to some of those he said
no he said
yes to certain things like quantum
entanglement
comes out of his theory and it's nowhere
present well
i shouldn't say i'll say it's nowhere
present in somebody like uh garrett
lisey's e8 theory
it actually um eric says it is present
in geometric unity
and i have to think really hard about
that because i don't uh yet
i haven't seen that mountain peak yet uh
but um
but garrett lisi is just you know kind
of a mathematical it's more akin to like
su5 or super strings it doesn't encode
within it
the laws of quantum entanglement the way
that stevens and eric's eventually will
okay so by definition a theory of
everything
is a is a connector of all the theories
we currently have
will a theory of everything be
uh a starting point can it be the first
principles
from which everything that we know now
can be derived you've alluded that some
things come out of some theories right
quantum entanglement comes out of i
think you said eric's theory
um but can these theories of everything
whatever
whatever whichever one happens if there
is one and if it's the right one
will it serve as a first principle from
which
we get everything else or is it just a
connector of things that already have
their own sets of first principles
you know we can derive maxwell's
equations from what we know on e
m we can derive you know theories and
relativity and
and even i think schroedinger's equation
from first principles right
so can can you will this theory
serve that function or will it just be a
connector of things we already know
both eric and yeah according to both
eric and
steven yes it will be able to do things
such as you know the
quantum entanglement the schrodinger
equation you start with their theory
and get those things yes they are
they are products of their theory eric's
theory it's not so clear
that you can get the dirac equation but
you can get
uh you can get entanglement allegedly um
you can get things that that steven's
theory doesn't have
um which is uh to say dark matter eric
has a theory that dark matter
uh owes its origin to this chiral
asymmetry
the asymmetry between your left and
right hand
there's a similar analog to that and the
properties of particles in that we only
see
left-handed neutrinos do you know that
um that that's
true tony do you know how you can
remember that you only seen left-handed
neutrinos
no i don't know the answer to that so
um do you know that dna has a helical
structure
right and you know what shape he what
kind of helix that is
left or right-handed healing uh no i
know i've topped my head
so dna this is the way to remember it
you'll never forget it
so dna has the right to life
okay so it's a right-handed helix and
the neutrinos are the opposite so
they're left you're sinister neutrinos
are
mr ghostly product correct me in the
chat or if i'm if i'm wrong okay but
isn't that that's a cool
mnemonic mnemonic anyway um so
eric's theory uh presupposes that their
dark matter is essentially
uh opposite chiral particles so those
would be right-handed neutrinos
and those would not interact with um
with ordinary matter in the same way
that um
chiral left-handed amino acids
aren't digestible by ordinary bacteria
and that's how things like artificial
sweeteners work
and so there'd be this sort of different
dimensionality
that would be a parallel universe to the
ordinary matter universe
and those would explain why we don't see
dark matter now steven's theory as far
as i know doesn't explain that but what
it does explain
is why the speed of light is what the
what it is
and that actually is and so that's
different
what we'd like to know is how um how
it's possible
to get um i think tony
a lot of times these theorists kind of
over sell themselves like when you say a
theory of everything
i like you would want to have an
explanation for all the laws of physics
but that's not what they mean a lot of
times some of them do
it's not examinable for a theory of
everything
i think what what they mean is otherwise
you've got a theory of some things
right you got theories of a couple
things the problem is that they that the
the problem is that they use the grand
unified theory terminology gut they use
that already
so they can't really but that's actually
what it is in most cases in string
theory
string theory doesn't presuppose you
know that the outcome of it's going to
be schrodinger's equation
it start you know basically this you
know super symmetric 10 mentions but
yeah
it's it's like it's more like eric's
theory and eric's theory is more
properly named because it contained it
doesn't call itself theory of everything
and actually stephen doesn't call his a
theory of everything
and so none of these are really true
theories of everything that doesn't mean
they're not
important that doesn't mean that they're
not very interesting because what if i
to you
in 1897 you know that uh that the week
for
19 1857 that electricity and magnetism
are the same thing you'd say that's
silly
uh if i then proved maxwell's equations
that they're just manifestations of the
same underlying
um force field you would then say
they're unified so that'll be a unified
theory but you wouldn't say that's a
theory of you know everything if we were
just electronic beings
so it wouldn't it doesn't maxwell's
equations don't have within them
uh you know you know bells paradox and
and things like that no
no but i'm just saying that you know
these these theories that we do have
can start somewhere a first principle
electricity magnetism they have these
these properties and then you write down
those properties and from there you end
up with a set of equations that describe
the entire field
and that would to me if you're going to
have a theory of everything
then you're going to need to end up with
your starting point of your theory and
ending up with everything
otherwise it's a theory of some things
so um
how is this going to play out do you
think brian in science we've got
you've got some really unorthodox people
uh and by that i mean they sort of are
on the outside of mainstream
scientific community uh eric and and uh
stephen
and then you have others who are working
within the community how
how's this gonna play out and is it
really all that consuming to most
physicists or is it just something that
they
you know kind of play around with once
in a while
this theory of everything i think it's
very important yeah it's very important
let's stop calling the theory of
everything let's just call it like the
next generation theory
uh because well no this is what this is
what we're trying to do we're trying to
we're trying to unify everything this is
what's trying to happen so i think we
should stick with that because
that's what we're trying to say well we
can call it that yeah but we can call it
that but let's understand we don't mean
an airing case so let's take string
theory string theory has dominated it
sucked the wind out of
all of physics theory or most of physics
theory leaving very little attention
oxygen uh if you will for other projects
other things like eric's right so um now
that again so let's just stick to things
like that
so now why is that is that because it
had kind of the first mover advantage
is that because it was so mathematically
elegant and attractive
um that it was hard to resist um the
question that we have
you know to really answer is one of
sociology because uh in part what
happens is
we get a certain amount of attention on
a specific theory and then many young
people have to choose what they're gonna
do
for their phd and they go in and they do
their phd for somebody that's in that
field and they're very few people
all three of these people that i
mentioned so far
and even max tag mark is kind of outside
the realm
the most conventional one that's
operating in this paradigm
is stefan alexander you know but he also
you know he doesn't come up with new
theories of everything but he explores
the cosmological implications of them
and in the case of um lee smolin
and um and stephen wolfram and garrett
lisey nobody they don't have any single
graduates dude they're all
outside of academia so why is that why
is that coming
um why do they have now it could be
because there's such a dominance
of the prevailing modality of
approaching this which i think
they claim has proven to fail in other
words
they claim string theory has had no
successes it only works in extremely
contrived situations called ads cft
you know universes that are that are
collapsing uh you get all sorts of
interesting behavior you get symmetries
you get strings
uh but there's no evidence for any of
that there's no super particles that
have ever been found
so my good friend jim gaines you know
he's into even more
abstract notions of symmetries um
and and basically treating the universe
as a fractal and
and and looking at it and it's more
complex features rather than complicated
features and he's the pioneer in some
sense
one of the fathers of super symmetry and
and you know
he's not fully you know kind of behind
it right now because i think there's a
lack of evidence
that this is going down the right track
as beautiful as it is
we just don't have that and you see that
in cosmology too
you see people have a dominant paradigm
that they pursue and that the people
that are outside that that doesn't mean
they're
you know because they're you know
einstein was in the patent office uh and
i'm working in the post office
uh not to denigrate the post you know
but but that doesn't mean that
just because you're outside of
mainstream that you're right that's
right yeah
okay so i'm glad to hear that you're
getting some interest with young
up-and-coming students uh in this and uh
i think it's the right thing to do to be
an advisor for somebody
to study this as a career because that's
what it takes that's how
it gets done like you said yourself
people who go into the field they need
to decide what they're going to do what
they're going to work on what their
interests are and they need an advisor
to get them going and if there aren't
people in
mainstream academia doing this then
they're not going to get um they're not
going to get noticed and so or they're
not going to get started themselves so
so i'm glad to hear that you're doing
this uh with this
you're just going to get you're just
going to try and and uh recruit one
student
or maybe several start with one yeah
stevens asked me stevens asked me if i
have
uh time and you know capacity to help do
the similar thing with his project
i would love to do that um you know but
i have a day job which is running
you know a large lab group right and you
know serving with
as one of the co-leaders of the simon's
observatory which is a 100 million
dollar project that we hope to build in
chile in the next three years
uh so these are you know that's my day
job and i have to pay
you know my my attention to that and
you're doing a lot of too you're doing a
lot of really good stuff to let us know
about what's going on so that's cool too
yeah well thanks to you my channel's
really grown i started the year i had
100 subscribers and now i'm pleased to
say i have 8 100 subscribers yes
good stuff just keep trying go do it
link in the description box yeah
please do
yeah oh dr disrespect who is now on
youtube as well so yeah we have a lot of
star power here okay well
um i i know we got to go soon um uh
what were the give us the
the the big uh uh
you know high altitude uh look at what
this discussion how it went and
uh how they can see it and all that kind
of stuff before we leave let's get
let's send people to the right places
well i was very glad that um
there were opposing forces so sabine is
against eric
stephen wolfe from garrett lisey then
there's a guy james beecham who's the
experimentalist he was against
sabine i feel she's detrimental to
uh to physics because she's basically
raining on this whole parade of building
a future collider
then you have people like lisa randall
um who unfortunately you know her time
was cut really way too short on this
uh live stream but we hope to have her
back and she's got great ideas and
what's called effective field theory
that we haven't heard from
max tag mark is brilliant um you know
but he's
um i think you know he has this notion
that
um that you know essentially the
universe is mathematical so
of course we should strive to look for
mathematical elegance there should be
mathematical
you know symmetries that are observed
and
you know he's a very deep thinker very
creative thinker stephan alexander had
very cogent things to say about the
state of uh
where do we go from here and the value
of experiment
in this field even though he's a
theorist and then you know matt o'dowd
who's a
you know righteous astronomer in his own
right he and i were you know going
really deep and that channel is very
good pbs space time
exploring extremely complicated topics
what i came away with is a sense that
unlike sabine that we should not
um that should not has
should not have an outsized effect you
know the
fact that so many people are are looking
into what she says and taking what she
says you know
to heart i think we need to be a little
bit careful
in terms of how much influence a person
can
can have when that person has by her own
admission
not taking the time to really want to
understand the theory now i can
understand that because there's only so
much time in the day
but on the other hand you know she'll
say things like this is just these are
wrong but it's not i'm not going to
explain why
um and then she'll do a rap video or
whatever uh
you know she's she's a unique person and
i do appreciate
the fact that she's so bold and
courageous uh on the other hand you know
i would like these to keep going
i'd like to have more of these with
other people i see in the chat room
people are asking me about roger penrose
i asked him to be on i asked jan 11 to
be on
um katie mack all these others and we're
hoping to provide more of these
in the centennial year of the great
debate
the anniversary year of it and there are
extremely important
i asked people like ed whitton you know
who i didn't get a reply from
uh um
who did reply very graciously but he
wasn't available
and so i think we're gonna get more
interest in this and i think the
question is
you know can eric put this to paper can
steven
find applications outside of biology uh
you know math
mathematical complexity theory um
crystallography etc
can you know garrett lisi can he you
know is there any traction or is there
any time that these people can say
that this aspect of my theory is wrong
but now i see that there's another
avenue that's more promising
that's what i want to see i want to see
more of that the only other thing i have
to say
is that we're never going to be able to
test these using colliders i'm sorry
these things that we already know we
can't test with the collider
and and so the question of you know what
what do we do
there is one resource that we have yet
to take full advantage of
and it's called the entire universe and
i think cosmology will be
the proving ground for future theories
of everything
and so i'm kind of putting in a plug for
for people to not only explore
you know does my theory of everything
predict uh the schrodinger equation of
course that's awesome it's great
and even if you don't predict it even if
it's irrelevant like it is to
supergravity or whatever
um still predict something in cosmology
either at extremely early times or
extremely late times
predict properties of dark matter dark
energy because those we can test today
we have outpaced the rate of growth of
progress and particle physics
in our experimental cosmology laboratory
such as the one that i run
at uc san diego great okay
well um good i i would encourage you
guys
uh to definitely get over there watch
the whole watch the whole uh discussion
this has just been a brief
there's three of them yeah brief intro
into it and uh
to kind of wet your whistle i hope you
guys will check it out and um
uh and tonight don't forget yeah don't
forget tonight 11 o'clock i will be
uh with brian uh he'll be running the
show and i'll just be
sitting there waiting to talk about
different things and i'll be streaming
this on my channel
and chatting with you also on my channel
so join me tonight 11 o'clock eastern
next thursday and brian i need to let
you know this too i've got another
guest coming in for thursday hangout for
astro coffee
so we'll have to pick up in a couple
weeks i'm talking with matt kaplan from
illinois state university who's going to
talk to us about black
dwarf supernovae and um i wanted to read
about that
i wanted to learn more about that after
i read the article so he's going to join
us next week
and we're going to talk about that so
and we'll be back in a couple weeks
after that
to pick up where we left off so okay
guys
tonight um uh i will be there and uh
thank you all so much
for watching and on behalf of dr uh
brian keating thank you so much
uh for hanging out with us and as always
keep
looking up
okay
you